so right behind me you can see is the
Icefall about a hundred yards right out
of base camp and it's probably one of
the trickiest parts of the whole climb
and you want to be efficient and quick
through there for safety's sake so we
set up a little ladder training course
there's going to be 25 ladders sections
that we need to negotiate day in and day
out through the Icefall probably a half
a dozen times so we need to be dialed
and so that's all we're going to do this
little training course right out our
door here our first day with the spikes
on first day rigged up and we're looking
over at the Icefall up there we got that
big thing hanging over us and we just
take it one little step at a time and
the first step is getting comfortable
with this rigging getting comfortable
with these ladders and our systems this
one I thought of going across the
ladders with crampons on really scary
but they broke it down explained it it's
all pretty awkward these crampons on
metal ladders and the ladders are a
little shaky into a day like this just
practicing is gonna help us that first
time we go we actually go through the
Icefall we want to cruise it we don't
want to be clumsy around figuring out
these systems that we could have done
with less hazard down here and so that's
what today is about